there's a Wall Street Journal column
about marriage as a mirror of human
nature that says 40% of young adults say
marriage has outlived its usefulness
what do you think's going on I mean I'm
not surprised because these are young
adults who've like I think so I think in
London now and this will be true in lots
of parts of the West um about half of
kids will reach the age of 15 not living
with their biological
father half so
I guess these young people just look
around and they're like well it's like
evident to me that marriage isn't
working Mary eat's got this idea about
um motherhood and family KN as a mimetic
desire that the death of mothers and
families causes fewer people to see them
which causes fewer people to want them
which causes fewer people to to I think
that's definitely true and you can see
that in D actually with um like if your
sister or your close friend has a baby
you're more likely to have a baby in the
year or two following and vice versa so
if if the people around you are not
having children you're less likely to
have children yourself I think and
that's I think that's so interesting
because there's always been this
assumption by demographers up until
birth rate started really crashing in
recent decades that people would just
spontaneously decide once they had
access to contraception or whatever to
have 2.1 kids
that that was like the natural settling
point for the human species that we'd
all we'd all reach there and we just
stay there and that's clearly not true
because so many countries now are
falling way below replacement and I
think it's because actually there's no
law of nature that says that people
should want 2.1 kids people look around
them and they're like oh okay everyone
here has one or zero or six and then
that becomes as you say the mtic desire
I think that becomes what's considered
normal and humans are completely
obsessed with what's normal which is why
I'm just genuinely quite generally quite
skeptical of the idea of
um of people having this like absolute
agency or AB I mean we do clearly have
we do clearly have free
will but I think that what we consider
to be desirable normal the life template
is so
incredibly dependent on what other
people around us
think um which is I think exactly why
we've got into this downward
spiral in terms of fertility there's uh
I love your analogy or your conception
of prudishness and licentiousness that
we kind of flip-flop between the two mhm
which one do you think we're in now uh
Lous transitioning to prudishness okay
is this like the uh perill equivalent of
the Hard Men create strong times weak
men weak times blah blah blah loose
women create yeah right okay okay yeah
maybe I mean I think it's kind of
natural to
have I think there's always a bit of a
roller coaster within culture because
you reach a point where
um you know whatever particular excess
becomes obvious and then people start
quietly thinking hang on I don't really
like this and then some people start
saying loudly I don't like this and then
you know everyone kind of joins in you
know so on forever through history um
what's different about this one of
course is that we invented the
pill so previous periods of
licentiousness they didn't have the
technological means to sort of go all
the way with it there was a glass
ceiling on how Lous you could be without
incurring it on a costs yeah like you
always had some people some I mean
because it's women who like carry the
literally carry the consequences of um
of sex ass home marriage right there
were always some women who either
because they had to because they were in
prostitution because they were poor or
because they were like crazy Aristocrats
who just could be eccentric and get away
with it who would who would behave
unusually but most women in the middle
you know having sex is probably the most
consequential thing a woman can do
without contraception so most women
would take that decision very very
seriously for obvious reasons up
until the 60s and then it's all out the
window
and we can't uninvent that like the pill
is not going to get uninvented even if
all these I mean there is a little bit
of a reaction of the kind
of what I think of as the goop class
right women who are really into women
who are really into Wellness the goop
class yeah like really into into GR of
paltro yeah yeah what's what why is goop
what's she got to do with goop what's
that because there's this recognition
which I think is true that hormonal
birth control is bad for you basically
basally mhm and so there's a it's it's
not coming from traditional Catholics or
anything like that it's coming
from women who are I think justifiably
concerned about the health effects who
are doing things like fertility
tracking rather than hormonal birth
control like that's happening but I
don't think that I don't think that
Herald is a mass sort of rejection of
the pill okay dig into the goop class
for me then what are they doing so like
natural cycles for instance if you heard
of this I have yeah yeah Sarah Hill did
a great talked about a great study that
was done to do with uh attraction to the
partner when you were got together on
the pill versus off the pill etc etc
yeah I know okay so two things I know I
know quite a lot of women who have who
have who've abandoned hormonal birth
control and have ended up doing whatever
kind of well more like wellness
maximizing means of ftil you you can
also do things like tracking your like
making your exercise regime gel with
your your menstrual cycle and things
like that yeah so there's a whole
there's a whole wealth of like
technology enabled um uh reproductive
Wellness available which is which is
good I have nothing against it um I also
know so many women who've got pregnant
from doing that
accidentally what from their exercise
routine no got
pregant
um it doesn't work that well it doesn't
work that well like realistically
natural cycles is uh thermometer under
the tongue right yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's it's like a more sophisticated
version of just tracking the Catholics
have done
forever um but like there's quite a good
CH knew it was just Catholic technology
all over again okay so prudishness
prudishness to licentiousness and you
think that we're what sort of tumbling
just over the top of that super sex
positive into what's coming next I think
that I think that we're yeah I I think
the reason I booked it unexpectedly well
is because yes we're at that Tipping
Point where everyone's been privately
well not everyone but a lot of people
have been privately thinking this is
weird and then they and then someone
starts saying it and you're like yeah
this is weird I think that that I think
that's probably the point that we're at
I the only thing is though I don't know
if it's going to be as radical a period
of prudishness as we've seen
historically because we've got the pill
one right so that's like a completely
different material situation and two
because we've got the internet we've got
porn like that really going to be my
suspicion is probably what we'll see is
we'll see Elites reacting
against the lenes period we'll see you
know the goop class like the but also
the male equivalent you know the I mean
you know this the impulse control is
such an important element of living in
our kind of technological landscape like
if you can't put down your phone you're
never going to do well professionally do
anything yeah so the people who are best
able to resist all of the various
Temptations including sexual Temptations
of our new material conditions other
people who are most likely to find
themselves in the elites tell you what's
interesting conscientiousness is
moderately heritable like all
psychological dispositions and yet what
you're saying here is that the people
who are going to best be able to control
their reproduction are the people who
are high in conscientiousness which
means that you're going to select for
people low in conscientiousness who are
going to be having more kids on
average yes this is the future talking
talking about the the decline of um of
birth rates you know all of the people
who are uh anti-natalist or anti-
children or family creation but also
from the left need to read one book on
behavioral genetics to realize that if
you want your particular Phil
philosophical ideology political
ideology to keep going in the space of
100 years it's just going to be
ashkanazi Jews and Mormons and and you
guys are going to be because again
political ideology is like 60%
heritable I agree with you and people
have been worrying about this for like
150 years it's just that that like
you're familiar with Francis gton who's
the you know the Father the father of
eugenic he he was I as far as I I'm
aware I mean this was before they knew
what a gene was he was the first person
to sit down and draw up family
trees and realize that what he called
genius was heritable and wasn't it
hereditary genius was that not his first
thing that sounds right yeah and so
particular families were particularly
likely to generate these you know
prominent figures and obviously that the
sort of methodology he was using now is
seems really archaic and how do you
measure genius whatever um but he was
basically right he was basically
recognized that all of these things were
just basically every psychological trait
is heritable to some extent and I mean
that's where the the thing that people
forget about the agenics movement is
that it was it was Progressive it was
like self-consciously Progressive that's
how people understood themselves and it
was often anti-religious it was
anti-conservative it was seen as like
this Brave new scientific Frontier that
so many people R like it's it's i' I've
been um reading about this at the moment
for a p I'm writing and the popularity
of eugenics in the early 20th century is
like mindboggling and has mostly been
memory H holded branding problem just
needs needs new branding problem well I
mean we well what they were talking
about mostly the Genesis of the period
was using the state to either encourage
some people to reproduce or discourage
other people from reproducing and there
were some really
particularly in the states the use of
force sterilization did you come across
that um that particular lady who had had
I think it was uh the statement was uh
three generations of idiots are enough
yeah you saw that one exactly I can't
remember her name but yeah that was like
important case law in the states um and
yeah like really a lot of people were
sterilized during that quite brief
period in America not so much in the UK
but of course it was the Nazis that just
completely made that line of thinking
completely Unthinkable branding problem
I'm telling you so looking at this sort
of Lous prudishness Paradigm which I
think is really important I think it's
not anything that kind of has a
flip-flop seems to be accurate to me
because it always swings back and forth
yeah I found this article that said
looking for nads study finds teens want
less sex in their TV and movies have you
come across this that's very interesting
so younger Generations don't think sex
is necessary to the plots of most movies
and TV shows that's according to a
recent study from you CLA researchers
interviewed 1500 individuals between the
ages of 10 and 24 about the way that
they're interacting with media those
between the ages of 13 and 24 were asked
if they thought sex was needed for the
plot in entertainment and 47.5% of
respondents said it was not they also
said they wanted to see less romance on
screen 44% and more content centered
around platonic friendships
51.5% in a video UCLA released in
conjunction with the survey 16-year-old
respondent Anna said when there's media
with too much sex in me and my friends
often feel uncomfortable she later added
I feel that it is way too graphic the
survey also quoted pop star Olivia
Rodrigo's answer to the question of
whether or not she watched the HBO
series the idol I don't have the desire
to I remember walking out of Barbie and
being like wow it's so long since I've
seen a movie that is female centered in
a way that isn't sexual or about her
pain or her being traumatized what' you
make of
that um so is it just the girls who are
who are reacting against I'm not sure uh
say 1500
individuals uh no it seems like it was
it seems like it was both males and
females that were saying that I I've got
three possible explanations come to mind
the first is it's the girls not liking
porn culture fair enough I think that
it's not hard to find women young women
who've been raised in this you know who
had the internet access from the get-go
who absolutely hate porn
culture like hey what the boys are
expecting from them all of this it might
be that it might be
um differential fertility rates already
having an impact in terms of the
conservatism and religiosity of young
people because you know
um like in America for the first time in
60 70 years you've actually seen a
decline in Pro LGBT attitudes among
young people wow where's that coming
from well my guess is that it's coming
from the fact that basically since the
pill more conserv more religious people
having kids yeah and then that's already
starting to play out in terms of the
younger generations to be more religious
and conservative we're seeing that male
female uh liberal conservative divide
amongst kids as well though right so
presumably if you split that polling
down but it seems like everybody's
shifting a little bit further right
that's plausible yeah yeah all right
what was the third one uh like Xeno
estrogens it's
it everything all roads lead back to
Alex Jones ultimately I mean he was sort
of onto something wasn't he I mean that
it is possible that the sex recession
socalled is partly
hormonal it's partly caused by I mean it
might partly be caused by women being on
hormonal birth control which is changing
their sexuality might also be caused by
men being low tea so the low
testosterone for men do you want to hear
my real horseshoe theory for this okay
right so I learned this whilst talking
to Dr Sarah Hill who wrote this is your
brain on birth control right and um she
taught me that male testosterone levels
are mediated by the fertility of the
women in their local ecology so if you
were a uh male in their 20s but you
happen to be around a bunch of other men
or a bunch of other grandmothers perhaps
or a bunch of
children your testosterone levels drop
interesting and what you have are women
who are very highly artificially
suppressing their fertility so men are
able to smell the T-shirt of a woman and
be able to pick the one the one that
they most attractive to is the attracted
to is the one who is currently at that
stage of her cycle she's currently
fertile etc etc they can see they've
done studies where men watch women's
Silhouettes
walking and the women who are currently
during the 7-Day you can get me pregnant
period
they're the ones that they're most
attracted to the [__] silhouette of
the way they walk display high heels
replicate that that's the idea the high
heels make you walk distin make you look
so you have this recursive uh feedback
loop of hormonal birth control causes
women to select for men who are more
providers rather than protectors they
want provisioners right they want the um
academic and the resources more
agreeable they then either come off or
don't come off birth control but find
they come out this [__] hormonal
Fugue State oh my God who am I in a
relationship with but you also have this
effect on men too not only socially in I
noticed that lots of women seem to be
attracted to Timothy shalam who's
painting his nails and kind of blah blah
blah blah blah yeah but the
genuine physiological hormonal response
to men just being around lots of women
who are on hormonal birth control
now processed foods not enough time
outside not enough time time with
vitamin D not enough time with
friends but there's a big X Factor
apparently amongst testosterone
researchers who don't know why men's tea
levels have dropped the amount that they
have right it's about 1% a year every
year since I think 1950 wow so it's like
and then that goes to 100 and then it's
that again and it goes to 100 so it's
not how we're in minus [__] uh
testosterone soon but uh yeah so
hormonal birth control has a lot to
answer for I think it's a really tricky
trade-off isn't it because
like there are clear downsides to having
a bunch of low te men you know in terms
of in terms of fertility in terms of men
and women just fancing each other and
like having functional relationships but
also like high testosterone is also
associated with crime and violence yeah
so which you know do we choose to have a
society of kind
of sexless incredibly like
online Placid soy people yeah who also
are quite
chill and don't cause like enormous
problems I don't know that's like that's
like a genuinely hard thing to choose
yeah you could almost look at it kind of
like a disposition sterilization yeah in
a way
yeah yeah [__] yeah but then we had
problems with like like this is a real
problem with the military I'm sure you
know like massive recruitment problems I
thought that was because everyone's fat
and got diabetes Well that too right but
also not being interested in it men just
don't want to wage war yeah we can do it
from Modern Warfare or um I'm on Reddit
it's probably also partly to do with
lack of like faith in the nation like
being less patriotic in general like the
pool of potentially great soldiers just
get smaller every year and it's sort of
fine I guess we get away with it because
if we're not actually in a hot war and
if we we have loads of
Technology but you can imagine a
scenario where that becomes an enormous
problem like a mass mobilization I don't
know how we' actually Fair the uh
Chinese government banned K-pop you see
this cuz they didn't want what was it
they called them it was like [__] men
we don't want any more [__] men so it
was all of the Chinese male role models
were like super high te jacked dudes and
they didn't want this BTS Like
soy like culture infecting them that's
how they that's what they saw it
something I learned about that from um I
had a um r m who's a professor of
Chinese history and politics Oxford on
my podcast I didn't know this um in
China there's a very strong association
between communism and
masculinity and actually it's the old
pre-communist like Confucian soy boys
basically you know the sort of the sort
of like
intellectual
indorsing that's associated with
pre-communist
China and so some of the reaction
against feminization through K-pop or
whatever is associated with um
anti-communist feeling so this sort of
jenzy push back against romance this is
what I thought was super interesting
right so we've got uh your spectrum of
prudishness and Lous but it's not just
the uh short-termism
of uh physical desires being satisfied
there's also another level to this which
is to do with romance and how Central
your connection to another person a
significant other is right because that
kind of fits on the prudishness
licentiousness scale but it's also not
exactly the same like that would be
something that's slightly different like
how important is it that you find a
significant other and I think that at
least a little bit of that UCLA study
probably is Rachel Zigler Ziggler as the
new Snow White saying we don't need a
prince to come and save her she didn't
have a prince she had a stalker um like
a Sleeping Beauty can't
consent uh like I wonder if it's not
just a push back against the sex side of
stuff but the no man right just against
romance culture in general uh HSBC got
Emily radowski the tennis player to come
and do uh fairer Tales uh princesses
doing it for themselves which was a
rewriting of Cinderella Rapunzel and
Snow White where instead of waiting for
a prince the princesses went and started
their own businesses on their own and
invested their money wisely so I because
HSBC is really where we go for like
modern [__] dating culture so yeah I
just think that this jenzy push back
against what may on the surface appear
to be about sex may actually run deeper
the thing is that they're sort of right
the sort of a man a woman needs a man
like a fish needs a bicycle old line or
the line from glorious dyum I always
thought was really clever which is we
became The Men We once wanted to
marry I.E second way feminists were able
to do that
and I mean I always I always think this
about the sort
of the
disposability of men in modern culture
which is totally real you know the like
that that basic red pull position is
true there is this problem of men
basically not feeling having purpose not
feeling needed whatever women not
feeling as if they need husbands because
like they kind of don't you know if they
don't have to if they're not having
children or even if they do have
children you know they can participate
like it turns out that actually women
being slightly more conscientious than
men are for instance and slightly more
agreeable than men are is actually
really great in a sort of laptop job yep
economy brain based instead of Bron
based yeah like women are actually
slightly better not not not at the tech
you know you've still got overwhelmingly
male CEOs and things like that but in
the kind of the the the median range
women are actually kind of better
employees in service
economies you know the problem that men
are facing is not actually feminism as
such although feminism has kind of
accelerated some of these phenomena it's
just it's basically technology and
affluence in highly technologically
sophisticated and affluent societies men
who are not in this incredibly you know
far right
tail super successful intelligent
whatever just normal men have
less to do we don't need brwn like when
we invented the internal combustion
engine the importance of male muscle
power
dropped like a stone diminished yeah
yeah and then as soon as you had
equality in terms of access to education
and employment and you pivoted already
from that Bron based to brain-based
economy it turns out that women have a
kind of a genetic unfair Advantage with
the current working environment which
meant that the you like this is
something that the manosphere of the red
pill never really gets right like when
they talk about how uh women in the past
and the culture that they appli to their
dating made them happier they forget the
fact that women were largely Financial
prisoners of their partner because they
had nowhere else to go so yeah maybe
they were able to remain loyal and make
better sandwiches but how much of that
was by choice and how much of that was
Stockholm syndrome uh it's probably
better I
think well so the big problem with the
status quo right now where we have you
know women are actually earning more
than men are at most points along the
income distribution just not at the very
top like the gender pay Gap is basically
a result of the fact that you've got a
handful of male CEOs who make an
enormous sums and they you see that the
current PM of Iceland the country not
the uh [__] company uh is on strike
along with all other Icelandic women at
the moment over the gender pay Gap right
anyway you were saying yeah along pretty
much pretty much everywhere the outside
of Iceland and CEOs the gender pay Gap
is an artifact one of the fact that
there are some a small number of very
very high earning men and two of it's
basic it's basically a maternity Gap
it's actually just the fact that having
children yeah having children means that
you can't operate in the workplace in
the way that a man can like at the very
least when you're very pregnant and
you've just given birth you know but
women are choosing not to do that right
so if
you if you if you don't have children
and you are a sort of typical woman in
terms of being slightly more
conscientious slightly more agreeable
having all of these you know being more
probably me more punctual being a better
employee you do basically have more of
an advantage in the workplace than
another
man but this is completely unsustainable
because of going back to the whole birth
rates thing like any culture that just
stops reproducing
itself is not going to last it's either
going to just wither away and die or
it's going to be overtaken by some other
culture and I and I sort of think like
that that the answer to the riddle of
why every culture that we see on
historical record that has sustained
itself and flourished has being
patriarchal is possibly because a
culture has to be patriarchal in order
to reproduce itself like that's my black
pill reading this stuff dig into that
because it's very hard to be to have
lots of kids as a woman you can maybe
have one or two just about and it not
let affect your career but there's just
a
straightforward clash between the labor
market and reproduction for women that
you can kind of get away with if you
make enough money because you can pay
for nannies and all this kind of stuff
but for most women it's just
like that's just that's that they're
they're almost irreconcilable you have
to you have to trade off something and
what most women are choosing to do it
seems is that they're having Fe
children which for them personally might
actually you know the truth is like
children are are expensive and
knackering like they're wonderful they
are wonderful but if you've not had them
you don't know how wonderful they are
like once you've had your children you
just love them more than more than life
itself like every mother I know says I
would unhesitatingly die for my children
but if you've never experience that kind
of love and it's kind of thetical yeah
then why wouldn't you say actually no
I'd rather make this next promotion well
the modern culture prioritizes pleasure
in the Here and Now short termism over
everything else I think human beings
just do that as well yeah but maybe
there was I don't
know maybe you're right but it seems
like there was definitely a preparedness
to uh invest now for returns in the
future more so our ability to the
marshmallow test was more effective 100
years ago for most I think because
culture kind of I think culture serves
good culture serves the purpose of
channeling people's making people more
long- termist because our natural
inclination is to be short-term rest
most of us and or I mean the thing is
with having children is like you you're
short-term is cuz you want to have sex
and then oh whoops a baby came along
like normally you don't have to think
about that yeah that was Evolution's big
trick wasn't it yeah exactly but now
thought you were just having fun guess
what the next 19 years of your life are
locked off and I know there's like
there's a certain Elegance to that right
but we've lost that because
contraception and now there are still
groups there are still cultures there
are still there are are still people who
just love babies and will have loads of
kids because they just get so much joy
from babies which is great um like I'm
one of those people I would rather have
loads of kids and earn less money I've
like made that rational decision but a
lot of people for a lot of people that's
not an obvious choice some cultures are
still channeling people into being more
traditionist being more long- termist
but the mainstream culture absolutely
isn't doing that and the the very likely
consequence of that is
that I mean like I can't remember the
numbers exactly but South Korea you'll
know has the lowest fertility rate in
the world for every 100 South Koreans
there will be four great-grandchildren
right like there's never been a plague
that has knocked out that many people
the 96% Extinction rate over the next
100 years incredible of Koreans
remembering that we shut down the entire
world for something that kills 1 to 2%
of people yeah it's crazy yeah is the
most incredible evolutionary bottleneck
that we're going through in other news
this episode is brought to you by cozy
Earth we sleep oneir of Our Lives do not
spend 33% of your life in anything other
than unbeatably comfortable sheets
getting a good night's sleep is the
Ultimate Game Changer and the sheets
that you have are a massive determinant
of just how comfortable you feel cozy
Earth has the most premium bedding and
loungewear that I've ever found they're
made from super soft Visos from highly
sustainable bamboo temperature
regulating so you will sleep comfortably
all year round and an enhanced weave
quality that won't pel so it's higher
quality will last longer and you'll have
a more comfortable night sleep and wake
up feeling more rested and revitalized
plus there is a 10year warranty on all
of their products that's how confident
they are that they're going to last but
don't just take my word for it Oprah has
chosen cozy Earth as one of her favorite
things for 5 years in a row now you can
get an exclusive 35% discount sitewide
on everything by going to Cozy earth.com
slod wisdom and using the code modern
wisdom 35 a checkout cozy earth.com
modern wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout the interesting thing about
declining birth rates is that it's a
it's not an existential risk in the
traditional sense of permanent
unrecoverable collapse it's not a
classic version of it but it's it's a uh
population risk that's very unique in
that there's no smoke in the sky there's
no asteroid heading toward Earth there's
no there's no lead measure if you're
looking until it's way too late yeah
right you don't feel it getting warmer
you don't even feel it getting uh
quieter
because we've got an aging population
whilst a reducing uh birth rate which
means that you can have more people on
the planet while fewer are being made so
you can almost predict out that it feels
really counterintuitive yeah yeah is it
demography is Destiny yeah right yeah I
I definitely think that a big chunk of
it is this prioritization of the Here
and Now of pleasure of meaning did you
see uh the girl with the list on Tik Tok
no in this this needs to be for the
Perry pilled out there this needs to be
a part of it uh this girl wrote uh
3508 page long list and printed them out
on Tik Tok of all of the reasons why she
didn't want to have kids uh and these
aranged from things like literally a
parasite living inside of my body to
can't wear cute heels anymore to uh
unable to do brunch with the girls uh
and then she printed off like a onepage
list of reasons to have kids and now
like hashir with the list on Tik got
millions and billions of plays amazing
yeah I mean I guess she's kind of right
but the problem is that the thing you
have to have on that that reasons to
have kids is
like
like inexpressible
Joy meaningful experience of my life
yeah which to me does cancel out like
brunch with the girls well you can bring
your baby to brunch with the girls you
look and when it comes to heels look at
the shoes that you've got on today are
indeed I never heels anyway overrated
sparkly things so you know one of the
promises I had Mary abat on the show a
couple of weeks ago who's just
phenomenal um uh I feel like she's your
spirit animal um and she was talking to
me about very similar sorts of things
that the promises that women were given
previously uh you know the freedom The
Liberation ultimately do you think that
most women on are more happy with modern
sexual culture than they were previously
let's say 60 or 70 years ago um I think
no but the outliers are quite um
striking so there are
some the thing is that having the kind
of let's say like mildly patriarchal
kind of structure where the assumption
is that the men
do participate most in public life and
do the bulk of well I mean it depends on
what area you're talking about
materially right so in subsistence
cultures women do actually do loads of
economic work they just do economic work
that is compatible with also looking
after little children so like the man
goes out in the field and collects raw
materials and the woman processes the
raw materials at home while mining the
Toddlers and like sharing the the burden
of of CHA with her sisters and cousins
or whatever um the more recent model of
the breadwinner where the man goes out
and ears all the money and the woman
stays at home and does all of the
housework is is kind of historically
unusual it's not that it's not that bad
like actually it's it's it's fine if and
only if your husband isn't a
tyrant but if your husband is a tyrant
it's completely
disastrous so it's like for most people
it's fine for most women it's fine and
probably is actually better than like
the current the St the status quo where
women have to still do disproportionate
amounts of child care and house work and
do all of the you know all the pregnancy
obviously all the breastfeeding
obviously plus going out to work right
this is what feminist called the second
shift that you end up doing two jobs
that's I think worse actually what was
it didn't you say you'd worked it out
that you were doing a full-time job
breastfeeding yeah you were doing 40
hours a week of breastfeeding yeah yeah
that's the third shift yeah exactly like
crazy
levels of crazy levels of work that you
have to do which is obviously you know
joyful meaningful Etc but it like there
are only so many hours in the
day you like you
need it isn't feasible unless you have
loads of money available to you or
whatever it isn't feasible to not
have a husband father who goes out and
does all of that and still be as good a
mother as you want to be it's I'm so
interested in paradoxes you know Mary
taught me about a ton of them uh you
have the pill gets introduced increase
in single motherhood increase in
abortions like Paradox interesting
another one that I found from Candace
Blake who's over in uh Australia is
that gender inequality in the pay gap
between men and women positively
predicts both male and female
satisfaction in
relationships yeah that the more unequal
the earning opportunities are for men
and women skewed in the direction of men
not women
the happier both men and women are in
their outcomes in relationships and stay
at home dads is a very strong predictor
of divorce yeah if the uh woman is the
primary bread win a man a 50% more
likely to use erectile dysfunction
medication uh you know increases in
domestic
violence the women are more likely to be
uh on the receiving end of domestic
violence if they're the primary bread
winner because the male partner s
switches from a benefit affording to a
cost inflicting mate retention strategy
you know if you begin to feel a
disparity in mate value you have two
choices right you can either start to
raise yourself up or try to drag the
other person down and you know making
them fearful of you was a pretty good
way to drag them down but that be you
know that's kind of dark that being said
the patriarchy is so powerful that we've
somehow convinced women that they both
need to earn the money and that we can
stay at home while they bear the burden
of children so maybe this is just a scop
from all of us to not have to do
anything except for Xbox
now what we've worked what what what
we've discovered all right so I don't
really believe in
okay patriarchy clearly has like a
strict anthropological meaning in that
societies where only men are allowed to
to be in positions of power and
authority have traditionally been
described as patriarchal by
anthropologists we don't live in one of
those anymore we haven't lived in one of
those for a half a century now in that I
mean this country we've had like three
female prime ministers and so forth
right but I think that there's
also a different way in which people use
the word
patriarchal which still to some extent
applies to contemporary culture which is
that there's this quite
deep-seated feeling shared by both men
and women and I think cross-culturally
that masculine things are high status
than feminine
things and that's why you see this great
eagerness actually of women now that
they can to participate in like
masculine coded things to be what like
well professional work right that
there's been this Rush of women into
into into the into public life into
traditionally masculine roles there has
not been a rush of men into traditional
feminine roles not at all because
there's no status associated with them
because there no status associated with
it and I think often that's what
feminists are describing when they talk
about things being patriarchal like they
they recognize the fact that there's
that kind of status Gap remember who's
ascribing that at least 50% of society
is ascribing that like on their own
behalf right yeah you know like I this
is what Richard Reeves's book was so
interesting where he talks about heal
right what was it like health
education maybe like Administration or
something else yeah feminine jobs yeah
yeah more feminine jobs that there are
four times more female fighter pilots in
the US Air Force by percentage than
there are male kindergarten teachers in
America yeah makes sense yeah yeah cuz
that there just hasn't been this rush
for men to try and attain feminine
status right and I think
that I don't think that our culture is
misogynist right like Mis misogynists
exist there are there like there are
some of them out there but that's not
typical I think though
that this sort
of deep-seated
assumption that women
are that you familiar with the women a
wonderful
bias yes so this is the the cognitive
bias where people will tend to actually
prefer to sort of show kindness and
generosity to women over men in various
scenarios so like you know you see a
stranger drowning you're more likely to
jump into the water and save them if
they're female than if a male but both
men and women are more positively
predisposed to news stories that comp
ment women's outcomes or say that a
woman achieved something than say that a
man achieved something exactly and vice
versa is true too right which doesn't
fit at all with the idea that we live in
like a misogynous culture I don't think
that we hate women I think though the
way that women are sort of regarded all
else being equal is as um like your mom
like you love your mom you don't want
toey her
necessarily you don't necessarily
respect her I think that's the I think
that's the common way in which like that
I think that the the puzzle basically as
to why women are so consistently
regarded in a particular way
cross-culturally as being like lovable
but also a bit like lower status is that
women are considered to be kind of
adjacent to
children so in the same way that we love
children but we're not going to let them
vote right I think that what the human
brain does is it has this like it's like
there's men there's women there's
children so women are in a kind of
intermediary position and very often are
basically have kind of
childlike legal status which is why I
suppose ties into something that I've
been saying for a while uh modern women
have been taught that true freedom is
having sex like their brother and
working like their
father that's the Pinnacle because it's
this like clambering up trying to attain
that masculine status which for some
women particularly women who have a more
masculine temperament you know like some
women are more disagreeable and
competitive and not maternal and those
women have done well out of the changes
we've seen since the sexual revolution
in that they can basically live they can
basically you know live like their
brothers now pretty much most women
aren't like that though and aren't made
happier
by trying to be more male well Chelsea
conoboy in the New York Times last year
wrote that article maternal instinct is
a myth that men created no that's not
true yeah right like yeah you can go
around sort of pretending that's true
blw in the face but I just don't think
it's true it's such a a hydrae headed
problem that we're talking about because
it's the convergence of the denial of
sex differences uh this sort of tyranny
of the minority uh a selection for the
most outspoken gregarious amongster
group to focus on the outliers it's not
even tyranny of the minority as in some
underspoken class that's speaking up for
themselves but also tyranny of the
minority that appears to have have
outsized achievements like the male CEOs
that oh well that that's exactly what
we've got going on here that will skew
data that people will focus on and use
January January or February of this year
is the highest percentage number of new
female CEOs ever in America it was 30
4% of new of CEOs in America were female
new CEOs you go like that's insane
that's so that I would guess if you to
actually poll from a uh nature pred
position perspective that that's over
indexing for it like how many women
actually want that life that job CEO
sounds like a fantastic title but what's
the reality of ceoing I would hate
to stress you know it's horses for
courses and again like this is Peterson
[__] two 2018 stuff you know what I
mean right like how many times do we
need to bang this drum evidently more
because it's not happening one other
thing I wanted to really dig into what
do you think the Fallout of me too has
been now approaching 10 years
hence I often hear from men that they
are now more reluctant to go up to a
woman in a bar or whatever that there's
this problem of fear of being falsely
accused of something and so I think I
mean I believe them you know if that if
some men are experiencing that I'm sure
though what's gone on is that the men
who were already sexually aggressive and
likely to actually be you know me too
perpetrators haven't changed their
behavior at all and the men who've
started being really careful were
probably fine to begin with if you were
a raper
the social media campaign probably
they've got a hashtag on Twitter I'd
better stop going around raping yeah
which is I mean there's
a I
always I wrote about in my first book
and it applies to this as to loads of
things the problem of normal
distribution where you have some trait
which is arranged on a bell curve and
the problem is that if you apply some
intervention so whatever that is like a
a social movement like me too or some
policy change or whatever probably what
you want to do is you want to actually
Target one of the tals you want to like
oh so we've got the you know we've got
bell curve of sexual aggression and
there's this this like most aggressive
end who are causing no end of harm what
we want to do is make them stop but it's
you can't just apply an interven to that
to that point on the normal distribution
like it's going to shift in one way or
another and everyone is going to be
affected you're smearing the entire
group with the same solution so what you
end up with is moving the threshold for
being like reluctant to go up to a woman
in a bar or whatever slightly just to
mean that like some of the nice guys are
not doing it but it doesn't actually
improve it doesn't affect the rapists
and it doesn't improve women's
experience of it David bus's book bad
men talks about uh it's one man doing a
thousand sexual assaults not a thousand
men doing one sexual assault you know to
repeat offenders over and over and over
and over again uh and unfortunately as
well repeat victims there is something
about the way that again this isn't
victim blaming but there's like
something about the way that women hold
themselves where they showed this to I
think maybe criminals in prison or
assaulters or assault yeah men that had
assaulted people and showed them a
number of women walking and they asked
them to pick which one they would attack
if they were going to and they converged
on the same women uh so you know for all
that we can say you know it's not about
wearing the skirt it shouldn't be about
being in the dark alley at the wrong
time all the rest of it like
correct but there is something about
particular women
that causes predators to see them as
viable
prey does that excuse it no does that
you know is that them choosing it also
no MH but like this is just the way that
the world appears to be ruthless yeah
and it drives me mad that we tell lies
to girls all the time about this because
we're so desperate not to appear to be
victim blaming that will say oh no you
can you know you can behave like a man
you can do whatever you want go back to
some random guy's house it'll be fine
and then when it inevitably isn't fine
we're like oh well you know he shouldn't
have he shouldn't have been suchal
aggressive I was like yes obviously
but we don't you know I would love to
just like delete every rapist from the
world all at once I can't do that like
if the advice that I'm going to be
giving my daughters is is going to be
unfortunately different from the advice
I'll give my
sons what would be the advice that You'
give them like for instance don't go
back to a random man's house that you've
just met like basic okay like complete
considered to be completely common
sensical up until up until even like the
1980s you know this is like recent stuff
but basically unsayable now in feminine
circles at least except everyone quietly
says it you know well again it's the
stated and revealed preferences thing
like how many parents that will prosti
about this on CNN and say that you know
we shouldn't be telling women oh so
you're saying that we should just accept
the fact that men are going to do this
it should be it shouldn't be that women
should change their actions men should
change their behavior okay what did you
tell your 17-year-old daughter to do
last weekend did you did you say make
sure that you text me when you get home
make sure that you're home before 11 Etc
get unlicensed taxi whatever yeah State
didn't reveal preferences yeah and what
drives me bananas is that we there are
some girls who don't actually have
parents or friends or whoever who are
privately telling them the
truth you know all they get all they
hear is is is is the public misdirection
oh this is like the luxury beliefs of me
too in a way yeah and so I I feel as if
actually we have a duty people who who
are speaking publicly to tell those
girls the truth on the assumption that
they're not going to hear it from anyone
else the cultural surrogate
mothers in a
way
yeah you've got this line between
consensual and good which I think
relates to me too as well what's that I
think that a lot of what so I mean
there's a lot of things that came under
the me tooo Banner um some of it was
just unambiguously criminal and you know
Harvey Weinstein or whatever got sent to
prison for for criminal acts a lot of
what came up though a lot of the stories
that got shared with things that weren't
actually strictly Criminal they would
just it was just like bad behavior it
was behavior that actually in another
era you probably would have been
probably would have been called
ungentlemanly or something like that but
but that vocabulary isn't available
to a sort of contemporary feminist who's
really bought into the to to the sex
positive message and so they'll tend to
just talk about things being consensual
or not consensual and actually the
consensual not consensual bar is is like
a low one it's a legal bar it's not
actually a moral bar really like there's
a lot of there are a lot of things that
a man can do on a first date or whatever
that are legal but are
bad plenty but we don't really have the
vocabulary to describe them which is why
I try and make you know like the
feminist case for chivalry we shouldn't
have got rid of that as a concept like
when you have as Stark a physical
difference and psychological differences
between the
Sexes you know 99% of men can kill 99%
of women with their bare hands and not
vice versa we have to operate with that
with that
recognition chivalry in those
circumstances is obviously in women's
interests even if occasionally it will
mean being feeling slightly patronized
like who cares I'm so happy to have my
the door held open for me and my bags
are carried it's completely fine if it
means that someone's not going to
assault me yeah yeah I mean this is I I
quote you and Mary about this all the
time that it is a straight line from you
should hold the door open for a woman to
you shouldn't beat your wife it is one
just continuous women are worthy of
protection and there is an asymmetry
between what men and women can do and
again Rob Henderson's coming a couple of
days later than you it's like luxury
beliefs all over again like the women
who come from societies where their
husbands already knew that beating your
wife would be a bad idea or they had the
support networks where that wouldn't be
accepted were trying to
deconstruct a support structure that was
needed for the underclass women whose
husbands had grown up without a father
and whose stepdad had beaten them who
just presumed that the way that you was
supposed to be in a relationship was to
hit your
wife yeah I mean I just like Cheston
fence like the wisdom of it you know
this this idea from GK chest you know
you come across a fence in a field you
don't know what it's there for the the
progressive the reformer whatever
vocabulary he uses says we don't need
this fence let's tear it down whereas
the conservative says no let's find out
what it's for and then maybe we might
tear it down if it turns out that it
really isn't necessary I mean just the
whole last 100 years has been like non
indication of chesteron Spence principal
yeah and and I and I honestly think that
most of it actually has to do with
technology like much as I love to to
complain about my political enemies like
actually the main thing that's changed
for people has not
been the intellectuals of the 1960s it's
been
um
like the dissolution of the family has
as much to do with the pill as it does
with anything any feminist has ever
said you know like the real I I'm I'm
I'm very sort of materialist in this
sense I think the real engine of history
is is technology or as as Mary
Harrington our friend likes to say it's
um material reality plus memes meme
first explain later me and Mary are on
board with that what was it that you
told me me the last time we spoke the
washing machine has done more to
liberate women than any feminist ever
did that was Phyllis Schlafly's
observation like Phil shy is such an
interesting figure because she who is
this person so she was a 60s uh when was
she been born she she she was at her
height in like the 70s um and she was a
I mean she was one of these really
interesting women American well so she
build herself as like an American
housewife and she was she had I think
she had five kids um but she also was
like a foreign policy expert who'd
worked
in um um not Westminster Washington um
and had like incredible degree actually
of professional expertise but she always
build herself as like you know a lonly
housewife whatever and she led the
campaign against the Equal Rights
Amendment which was a second way
feminist effort to basically enshrine in
the US Constitution that men and women
are equal and order to have equal rights
and Schlafly said in retrospect not
unreasonably men and women aren't the
same
and so actually if you were to enshrine
this in the Constitution you would
frequently end up with things with with
you know having to do things actually B
not in women's interests so the example
she like to give because this was during
the Vietnam War was you want to get you
want to see women drafted because that's
that's where that ends up if you say
that men and women are the same then why
wouldn't you draft women why wouldn't
you be sending pregnant women into
combat men and women you know men women
the same whatever and second feminist
used to say cuz anti war they say well
we don't think anyone should be drafted
I was like okay okay but if you're
trying to like future proof your
Constitution which is I think very much
the point of the
Constitution that does seem to be an
obvious I mean I don't completely agree
with schafle one of the things she used
to do which I find so cringe is whenever
she showed up at a public event she used
to thank her husband for allowing her to
be
there I I don't do that when I go to
public EV so like she was she was of a
different time in that sense okay so I'm
not I'm not going to hold f slly up as
like feminist poster girl but she did
like she had insights at the time which
on which she has been proven right um
and the Equal Rights Amendment was never
passed because of her efforts what do
you think about this lack of approach at
the moment uh Alexander one of my
friends Alex staty uh put a study up
recently uh 50% of men aged 18 to 24
have never approached a woman in person
in their life and uh even higher
percentage 18 to 30 haven't approached
woman in the last year is this
Downstream from me
too I have a sightly weird take on this
which is that actually the thing you
hear about as sort of the thing that Gen
X people talk about of going up to
someone in a bar and this being a way of
striking out relationships I think that
was a very brief period of History sort
of post-sexual Revolution but pre-
internet where that was considered
normal um and I'm slightly too young to
have ever actually experienced
that the normal way actually that people
start relationships in the vast majority
of cultures is to be
like is like semi- arranged marriage
right like not the full you've never met
this person before you know 13year olds
whatever getting betrayed like not like
that but the sort of you're introduced
by family members mutual friends you're
known in the community you go to the
same church whatever it is and then your
both of your families like consent to
the marriage
and it works out okay but that but the
expectation isn't like the expectation
of marriage up until relatively recently
was that you would have an economic
relationship a you know and a
reproductive relationship but you
weren't best
friends and actually I don't think I
don't think husbands and wives used to
talk to each other as much as they do
now I think people used to have much
more homosocial kind of lives you'd hang
out with other men you'd hang out with
other women you wouldn't necessarily
hang out a lot with the opposite sex
including your spouse um so this idea
that like the going up to a person in
the bar is like the normal and natural
way of starting relationships I don't
think is historically accurate that's
interesting so the male
aversion felt fear of approach anxiety
which every guy listening is aware of
apart from the psych paths right there
is a girl that I find attractive that I
either know or don't know or partly know
or whatever yeah hi how are you nice to
meet you is kind of like a miniature war
that you have to go to and the felt
sense of palpable fear is just ripping
you apart
inside that
isn't or the modern aversion to that
isn't some novel new problem it was a in
your opinion here a bar that kind of
never really needed to be gotten over
over in the first place in some regards
because you had seen each other at
church for ages or her father owned the
farm next to your father's land and you
guys had known blah blah blah like yeah
yeah people have much more kind of
static social lives so yeah just
approaching some
stranger and ending up getting married
to her is not I had this uh I had this
conversation with a guy called mads
Larson who is a mating ideology
researcher I'll send it to you it's
phenomenal
and he talks about
this all of the different uh
Arrangements that people went through
and the uh romantic to the confluent
which is what we've moved through most
recently has left us with a really
interesting vestage which is previously
it was they own the the farm next door
it was almost like a tactical marriage
between the two of you and then it's no
no no no you're supposed to you guys are
supposed to be together forever you know
there is supposed to be deeper meaning
instantiated in this but then as soon as
you have the sexual Revolution you have
Confluence so for as long as you can
benefit me and I can benefit you I think
even Mia Khalifa who obviously Paragon
of sexual virtue uh said on a recent
interview that um people think that
marriage is some sacred thing it's not
it's just a piece of paper and if this
person isn't helping you grow it's time
to move on um so they just confluent
like uh ideology there helping you grow
from the center you need to be helping
them grow yeah I'm not sure yeah helping
you prepare for your next porn scene I
don't know whatever she meant um so you
have this really interesting thing which
is that both the two most recent
cultures have kind of got like
conceptual inertia inside of our heads
that we have this sense and we were kind
of told and maybe some people think that
it's true that you're supposed to find a
person who fulfills you who is your
Confidant your best friend your uh the
sexual Paramore your the co-owner of
your children and the household told and
all the rest of the things yeah and yet
modern culture is this more Confluence
thing which is they're supposed to
benefit you and help you grow and these
two things kind of bounce off against
each other and then you know if we look
back ancestrally at what we're
predisposed for it's [__] neither of
those two right like you can say what
you want about the truthfulness or
utility of both of those it wasn't that
and it seems Seems like serial monogamy
is what we built for some combination of
polygyny and serial monogamy uh and all
of these the existing B rate of what we
are plus the two most recent cultures
are just like like the Bermuda Triangle
of mating ideologies inside of our mind
yeah there's this book called the um the
All or Nothing marriage which is about
sort of yes this modern conception of
marriage
where where exactly this you put so much
expectation on your spouse that they
will
be you know you will be perfectly
sexually compatible perfectly like
conversation compatible per you know
everything everything is perfect and
obviously for loads of people that isn't
going to be true and that's not going to
be true for 60 years or whatever that
you might be together um and so you end
up with this All or Nothing thing that
like some people have absolutely
fabulous marriages and some people just
they can't possibly take the strain and
so they collapse and the authors compare
it to um maso's hierarchy of needs where
like if you're in a position if you're
in a situation of economic subsistence
you basically just see your spouse as
like your economic partner with whom you
have children but your expectations are
not that high and then you reach the
point where you're so affluent right in
contemporary culture where you kind of
regard marriage as yes as fulfilling all
of these like esoteric psychological
needs which is just not reasonable so I
honestly this again Mary Harrington
endlessly quotable she has this uh this
this this saying that we should abolish
big romance yeah that the idea of having
these incredible like romantic
expectations of your spouse is just
pretty much setting yourself up to fail
one woman meeme machine isn't she she
really is um what was your thing it was
you that reminded me of a story that I'd
forgotten from my childhood about uh
ladies dropping
handkerchiefs oh right as a way of like
demonstrating interest yeah so I had
this thing with me and David bus came up
with this solution uh around women
cultivating receptiveness if they want
to improve prove their dating Prospect
now in a post me to world where we're
worried about uh women's safety
especially sexually this is something
that is kind of difficult to say but
again if you want to work within the
confines of how reality is not how you
want it to be I think that women
cultivating
receptiveness accounts for the male
approach anxiety problem right that you
know a a slightly lingering a longer
lingering eye than you think or like you
know smiling at somebody as opposed to
doing the why men love [__] treat him
mean keep him Keen kind of approach men
are going to be so bad at receiving
those signals though don't you think
have you ever heard that a a the average
man of 130 IQ has the like emotional
social receptivity of a woman with 70
IQ like the difference this is what my
husband so you're saying we're actually
socially [__] yeah my my husband and
I my husband calls me a witch because I
can like to like sense there's something
off you are particularly witchy today
with the with the olive as well yeah I
think it's just women I think we are
just wi witchy that's why you were
burned at the stake bring back you can
just like sense that something I don't
know facial expressions whatever
something which most men are just
oblivious to with with some exceptions
clearly okay so yeah well let's take
that as the again the thermodynamics of
the situation that men are uh their EQ
is 50% of what a woman's is essentially
um if that is the case leaning in even
further to not being receptive is going
to make said blinker man even less
capable of understanding that maybe
you're interested oh yeah yeah right so
I just think
that again another Confluence of the
hydra's head of lots of stuff that's
going on the multifactorial problem uh
women are maybe being a little bit more
masculine working in more masculine
environments thinking they need to be
more disagreeable to be more effective
at work concerned about their unsafety
uh generally skeptical of of men that
come up to them strange men that come up
to them in a bar which has led to
absolutely less receptivity from women
and it's like look if you are
complaining like where are all of the
Good Men at look around a little bit if
you can when you're at your CrossFit
class or you're doing yoga or you're
doing whatever and if someone if some
guy comes up to you and asks some
awkward clunky question but he's kind of
cute like don't just presumed that he's
asking the question like use the witch
Clairvoyance right tap into the astral
realm or whatever it is that you do and
think oh yeah have you heard of the the
male overperception and the female under
perception bias is this with sexual
interest correct yeah yeah that's in
David David bus's book that men uh
overestimate the degree of interest that
women have to them and women
underestimate which is largely why you
have awkward passes by uh male
co-workers and stuff well what do you
mean like her eyes and you saw the way
that she looked at me every time we went
to the copy machine or whatever you know
alcohol exaggerates that does it really
yeah wow so men are more likely to
falsely perceive sexual interest when
they're drunk fantastic which again just
makes so much sense of all the you know
like were you um you know that there was
like me too but for schools in the UK a
few years ago it was called everyone's
invited it was like a website that some
some girls set up to to describe like
bad sexual experiences that they'd had
with um what they in school well not
also not normally in school this was the
thing so it ended up being a big um
headache for teachers and head teachers
because parents were obviously really
upset understandably um and they said
you know you should be teaching consent
workshops in schools you should doing
all these things and the teachers were
like this isn't happening in school very
rarely is this happening in school this
is normally happening happening Friday
night at some house party the parents
aren't there everyone's
drunk and like it's kind of the parents
responsibility honestly to stop that
step in yeah and it's like look you've
got horny young men raised on porn plus
alcohol young women often giving
confusing signals I mean one of the
things that like teenage girls just
don't understand bless them is like if
you if you say Dre and revealing clothes
because you want to attract a particular
man that the blast radius of that signal
dir bom yeah like I was I was getting a
train recently in London and there was a
school girl who was probably like 16 who
was walking ahead of me and she was
going up the
stairs and she was wearing such a short
skirt going to school that I could see
absolutely everything and I like I
almost jogged after her just to say like
you're lucky it was me who was walking
behind you and I know that you're doing
this
because you want to feel like there is a
kind of thrill of feeling sexy that
young women experienced for the first
time and they have no
idea how potent and dangerous that that
tool is so you know you do it because
there's like a particular guy gets the
same train as you who you want to catch
his eye or whatever fine but like I
could have been a creepy bloke and this
is why I think parents have to
be banning their daughters from leaving
the house looking like that basically
because they have no idea like teenage
girls are just I mean teen you know
teenagers are dumb the the sort of me
too conversation around victim blaming
and and and stuff is such a deep hole
when you get into it to talk about
should things be this way no are things
this way yes do you want to play within
the confines of the thermodynamics of
this particular system well you probably
should right and to thread that needle
especially
because I I often think about this um
Douglas Murray once taught me that it
doesn't really matter who makes the best
logical argument in a debate if you
manage to get two or three big laughs
you win yes that's true and it's almost
it's all Vibes yep it's Just Vibe you're
a Vibe architect right the problem with
this discussion if you have somebody who
is very anti- this and is saying that's
victim blaming you absolutely you saying
that you're giving men a pass you're
saying that women should be fearful of
what they should wear and it's like that
particular talking point is
so empathetically robust in its
signaling that it almost always wins
yeah because the
most obviously caring argument upfront
that sounds like the one that sounds
right that sounds like the one that you
will get the most support for on
Twitter is so tough to put it's like
right yeah yeah no I don't
disagree but look at the outcomes that
we get from this one of the things that
um progressives really have on their
side rhetorically is that if you're if
you're a conservative who's saying look
actually you know there was a line that
one of my readers sent me from a from
all places it was a book about um uh
making wine and the line was um
Traditions or experiments that
worked you can say that when you're
talking about wine making and it's not
too like politically explosive but you
can obviously apply that to to to to
social issues
well experiment that work exactly but
what you end up if you're trying to make
that argument and if you're and if
you're you know proposing anything
remotely conservative is that you have
to you you end up having to defend other
cultures or cultures of the past so
you'll say look actually you know there
was a lot to be said for the sort of
slightly arranged marriage there's a lot
to be said for teenage girls being
encouraged to dress more modestly
whatever and people say oh what so
you're saying that you support domestic
violence you're saying that you support
you know Cher and imperialism and like
everything that might have happened
during the era that you're talking about
and you have to say no no no I don't
know I mean you just ends up with the
back foot whereas if you're a
progressive you can say I can see this
Vision you know like in the future we'll
have this amazing Society where
everything's great and the fact that
this is this has never happened and is
never likely to happen means that you
never you're never in the position of
having to defend anything unfortunate
you never have to talk about tradeoffs I
think that like acknowledging the
existence of trade-offs is a
fundamentally conservative trait yeah
Thomas Saul there are no Solutions only
trade-offs yeah it's really painful but
it's true unfortunately you'll have seen
a lot of the stats coming out about the
happiness or lack of amongst young girls
M you
know 60% of girls aged 12 to 16 have
regular or persistent feelings of
hopelessness and stuff like that what's
your assessment of the current mental
health of young women I mean it seems to
be really bad the the I mean there's all
the obvious stuff um about why you know
young people they don't go outside
enough they don't do enough exercise all
that but that's that's true for boys as
well I think um Jonathan Heights and lot
of work on this that the main thing
that's going on for girls is social
media because girls use social media
differently from boys one of the ways
that girls use social media is to
torture each
other right girls are so like you know
that all basically all contagious mental
illnesses start among and predominate
among teenage
girls things like some like anorexia for
instance is like a classic example or or
like now apparently all these teenage
girls have got two reps that they
acquired from Tik Tok there was a period
where uh multiple personality disorder
and there others were coming out on Tik
Tok too precisely and I think it's
because it's kind of like that witchy
thing we were talking about earlier like
women being very very socially sensitive
for obvious evolutionary reasons you
know that women being smaller not having
the kind of physical capacities that men
do the main advantage you have in terms
of your own Survival and survival of
your children is making
alliances particularly among other women
you know recruiting other women to
assist you in your endeavors and
whatever requires this social
sensitivity and I think that that can
misfire in terms of say being so
receptive to whatever getting tats from
Tik Tok that you that you know you do
you do yourself harm basically I mean
it's not terrible harm but like anorexia
is terrible harm right that you might
acquire sort of
mimetically um and I think also it means
that girls I mean one of the things I
always think about in Instagram it's
like the it's the image based social
media which seems to be particularly bad
for girls um Twitter is bad for
journalists it sends them completely
insane Tik Tok and Instagram sends
teenage girls insane I think it's
because um one of the things that uh
looking at these these these platforms
one of the things it does with girls is
it gives them a completely false
impression of their intersexual
competition
that normally they would look around at
the young women they actually know who
are as like plain and normal as them
skinny and acne ridden as they are yeah
and think oh okay right yeah this is
like this is basically my my like
competition pool for acquiring whichever
like equally mediocre looking man right
whereas now you look at Instagram and
you see the most beautiful women in the
world airbrushed and having had plastic
surgery and you think that's your
intersexual comp competition so I think
it just kind of I think it just plays
complete Havoc with their
minds this also explains the uh social
contagion theory for FTM transitions
yeah because if the you've heard of the
uh left-handedness argument for Trans
people right that as soon as you remove
the societal impositions and judgment
people can truly be their real selves
okay if that's the case and that very
well May
contribute if that was entirely the case
why is it four girls that all sit
together at the same lunch table in
school right like why is it not evenly
smeared across the entire populace it's
not it clumps together right right um
it's also gone from being like diagnoses
of gender dysphoria have gone from being
primarily a male thing to being
primarily a female thing like by a big
margin like the huge explosion has been
among teenage girls
specifically there was a a study in
Finland that I found that I put in my
newsletter last week uh that said they
could attribute
15% of the negative mental health
outcomes of teenage girls to their use
of birth
control right and I I realized this when
I spoke to uh Dr Sarah Hill last year uh
as as she's talking to me about how uh
young forming brains can have particular
types of negative mental health outcomes
locked in for life if you're on hormonal
birth control during this particular
period and I remember thinking about the
coddling of the American mind at the
time and going I 100% bet that no one's
factored in the base rate of the
increase of hormonal birth control and
the uh predisposition that it's caused
amongst young girls yeah yeah yeah I'm
sure that that's
true this sounds random but that
I there's this debate you might be
familiar with about whether or not it's
ethical to use chemical castration for
pedophiles in some countries they do so
like Germany I think is an example of a
country that will that will offer
chemical castration as an alternative to
prison time and actually oh it's an
alternative yes or maybe you have it
when you're on pretty sure Alan churing
got something similar like that which is
one of the reasons why I think it's not
popular in the UK right because churing
is a famous example of it being used um
against g m yeah um but a lot of
pedophiles will say that they would
prefer that and that actually they're
really tortured by that I mean I I I am
generally of the opinion I think that
this is scientifically sound that it it
is an innate sexual orientation that is
found in a small number of men and a lot
of them report being absolutely tortured
by it it's awful it's like the most
stigmatized like you wouldn't wish it on
your worst enemy what what a horrible
curse right they would actually choose
chemical
castration to relieve them of that and
and yet there's a there's a general
feeling at least maybe in the
anglosphere that there's something
really dodgy about using sort of
pharmacological punishments right and
you can imagine of course using in other
contexts as well you might sedate
aggressive you know whatever um I was
talking to a friend about this who works
in politics and who's a gay man and and
I was saying well you know you could use
like you know that the arm the implants
you get in your arm you could you could
use that to sort of release small doses
of this every day and he said the
implants you get in your what and so
well you know you can get hormonal
contraception either you get in your arm
or you get the like the the the um int
usine devices or whatever which secretes
more he had no idea because he's like
innocent to these
um but it occurred to me like isn't it
crazy that we're so it seems so outside
the Overton window to um use
pharmacology to like alter the minds of
criminal offenders and we've had teenage
girls on these drugs for a decade like
we know them to be mind altering to some
extent wow and we put like no hesitation
about putting an arm implant in like a
15-year-old
girl um was basically quite an
experimental
drug I mean the argument against is to
say yeah but pregnancy is also a pretty
like poor outcome for a 15-year-old that
but also quite an extreme thing to go
through full stop physically mentally
Etc so if the choice is pregnancy or
hormonal birth
control hormonal birth control has fewer
side effects it's you know there are no
Solutions only tradeoffs right and it's
rough man I I think about some of my
friends who've got young girls that are
you know maybe 12 or 13 and are going to
be starting to be around boys that can
get them pregnant and they're going to
become sexually active at at some point
in future but also know about the risks
of hormonal birth control and don't want
to condemn their beautiful daughter to a
life of potential you know 10% more
anxiety and depression risk plus the
weight gain and the all the rest of the
stuff but also really don't want them to
get pregnant at at 15 and you go okay
are you again playing within the
confines of the world as it is not as we
want it to be saying oh make sure that
you use protection and make sure that
like you don't get too drunk and bl it's
like they're 15 or 16 or 17 or something
you know yeah you said there about the
um
uh sexual predisposition of the
pedophilia being a sexual uh orientation
ped's got a famous question which is
what do you believe that most people
would disagree with and for a long time
that was mine
that uh non-offending pedophiles need
way more sympathy than we give them uh
because I've had a bunch of
neuroscientists on the show and they've
put people in fmis with arousal
responses uh and they can
show non-offending pedophiles everything
they can throw every sexual Kink Under
the Sun at them
nothing and then they are able to show
them something that tickles her fancy
and it's really disturbing isn't it it
would be so it would actually be so much
more like
psychologically reassuring which is why
I think most people prefer this
explanation to think that it's just some
manifestation of evil or something or
it's under people's control cuz it's
just it's awful to think it's so
uncomfort imagine being cursed with that
awful I remember learning about it I was
at Uni and there was I was dating this
girl a smart doctor medical student girl
and she taught me about this and ' given
a presentation on stage basically saying
like you know the we need to give these
people more sympathy uh because it
wasn't that long ago that gay men were
seen basically as the same now the
difference being that gay men could
enact or not they couldn't but they were
in the right future able to enact it
without doing something that was taking
advantage of a person that can't consent
yeah but ever since that I've always had
this in the back of my mind as one of
those was and yeah the discomfort it was
the same reason I think that even before
the lab leak hypothesis was something
that was put forward people were so
prepared to lay CO's Origins at the feet
of a malign scientist because it was so
much more comforting than believing that
it was the chance mutation of some silly
little microbe because one or normal
failure one at least was just not cha
yeah yeah and it felt like it was more
in your control with the right
intervention we could have fixed it yeah
it's like no you can't yeah yeah I read
someone I forget who now but um I read
someone um writing about um uh Israel
this is relevant I swear the and the the
failure to the the failure of the of of
the the Gaza borders and and the fact
that Hamas were able to get through on
um uh on 7th of
October and the so many people have
assumed that there was some sort of
conspiracy at play you know that it was
that there was it was it was either you
know some faction within the Israeli
government or the Americans or you know
whatever conspiracy you fancy for
deliberately permitting Hamas to do this
in order to whatever justify flattening
Gaza whatever it is and this writer said
isn't you know isn't it telling that
people will jump to that conclusion
rather than the much more likely
conclusion which was normal failure
which is that when you have any kind of
complex system
like sometimes there's a blow a BRK yeah
and that that's actually true of
everything like what a horrible thought
but but that's actually our entire
civilization is basically resting on
these very very delicate complex systems
no one really understands Matthew Sayad
wrote in the times the bias is called
compensatory control uh so when things
seem like uh outside blower brisk has
occurred we want to lay it at a sequence
of events that at some point we could
have interjected a compensatory control
it's almost like magical thinking isn't
it it's like you know praying to the
gods to send rain or whatever it's that
feeling of wanting to have some kind of
external agent who controls all of this
because it's actually so much worse to
think that it's that it's random you
spoke about uh inter seexual competition
I've got a pretty spicy theory about
body positivity that I want to teach you
about so this is the Rivalry theory of
body positivity and the tldr is female
support for body positivity is at least
in part fueled deep down by female
intersexual competition which pushes
other women out of the dating pool by
discouraging them from losing
weight I mean yes but I also think to
some extent it's just
cope it's just it's just trying to it's
just because it it's because sexual
attractiveness is like brutally
hierarchical it just is for men and for
women I mean for women it's more
physical for men it's more two status
and what but it like is just brutally
hierarchical um and no one particularly
if you have a generally egalitarian
Outlook if you're on the left um no one
wants to face up to that particularly if
you're at the bottom of the hierarchy
and so trying to say oh no the hurcan
doesn't exist actually and trying to
persuade men to agree with you is one
way well exactly but it is one thing
that you can do um you probably can't
persuade men to think differently but
you can I don't know get into like
Lululemon ads or no one no one's ever
been guilty into an erection I don't
think it doesn't work no well you you
try you can try harder but this whole I
mean like there's a there's there's also
a deeper principle is there isn't there
that like human nature is kind of
immovable not completely like we do have
a little bit of control over ourselves
and there are like there are there are
cultural structures that will
incentivize some things and not others
and whatever there is room for maneuver
but we basically have some fairly tight
um controls around us at all times well
it's what I've got in my head is kind of
human nature is easier to constrain than
it is to enable in that regard like it's
already operating at Max RPM and you can
bring that down with social norms and
and judgment and stuff uh but going the
whole argument of uh
a m Toof transition if you as a straight
man are not attracted to that person
regardless of how they
present you are that's homophobia trans
phobia or whatever uh actually don't
know which of those two it is
um it just doesn't play within the
confines of of reality yeah right and
actually that's one of the things that I
think is so cruel
about so much of the sort of discourse
around trans like there's this line
actually there's this great um there's
writer Andrew longu who's who is trans
and who disagrees with me on absolutely
everything but I would say he's a great
writer right really really good pros and
sheu has this line when you are trans
you become permanently dependent on the
kindness of strangers in the sense that
basically no one passes it's really hard
to pass convincingly particularly if
transition as an adult it will always be
kind of physically
obvious that you're not actually a
natural female what you depend on is
people playing along every single time
every social interaction for the rest of
your life so as not to feel dysphoria
and sometimes people won't do that
little children aren't going to do that
or like some elderly person with
Alzheimer's isn't going to do that you
know people aren't always going to cut
and on that they're supposed to play
along yeah and so it means you have this
incredibly fragile yeah it's a social
mindfield it's terrible yeah and what
you're basically and and that's what's
being inflicted on people when they're
encouraged to go through irreversible
surgeries living their entire life
dependent on the kindness of strangers
for for like to avoid complete
psychological dissolution Douglas
Murray's got this quote that he throws
around saying um you know when you've
reached true equality because you have
to put up with the same level of [__]
that everybody else does that's true yes
and um the lack of special
dispensation is the exact opposite uh
and you know I
think it's all about dispositions
but I think if it was me and I was being
coddled I would feel incredibly
patronized uh and this is how I think
you know to even put regardless of
whether the L's the G's the B's the
t's as groups want to be together it's
not like T is just a group or G is just
a group right within that you have a
number of different factions of people
and uh yeah I I don't think that I that
wouldn't be how I would want to be
treated what was your what's your theory
on the normalization of cos atic
surgery I think that unlike
other Industries which are more
obviously Supply demanded whatever I
think that there is a
completely bottomless desire from women
in particular for beauty enhancing
treatment and they will basically spend
as much money as they can right on
average and that the thing that really
drives the beauty industry is
technological innovation so like as soon
as something new comes on the market and
it's typically very expensive and then
only celebrities use and it trickles
down whatever like I didn't know this
for
instance it wasn't that long ago that
actually dyeing your hair was considered
to be quite unusual for women who are
going
gray that was considered to be kind of
in the Realms of like quite not extreme
but like quite uh you know expensive
time whatever like it was at the edges
of what was considered normal for women
saying their 50s or 60s now everyone
dies their hair basically now going gray
is a weird statement
and we've had this like ratcheting up of
the things that you have to do in order
to be considered well
groomed and the sky is the
limit and so it's and and it and it's
just driven by what's available so now
it's not just wearing makeup it's also
fillers it's also Botox it's also weird
wonderful facials whatever like all the
all the things that you can do having
your you know having your nails down as
like a standard as a completely standard
thing right it's really expensive to
have like perfectly manicured nails all
the time and women women who don't have
much money will send so much money on
this it's
amazing um and I mean what a wonderful
time to have invested in the beauty
industry because honestly the tech that
the tech that they do is actually
incredible what you mean what like
like okay Nails one example men won't
know this the the the bottles of nail
varage that you can get in the pharmacy
for like a few pounds they'll the
manicure will look really bad and it
will last you a few days
so presumably back in the 50s when we
used to do that but no one does that
now maybe 10 years ago it started to
become possible to get manicures that
would last for 10 days but they're quite
bad for your nails because they have to
like soar away at it basically when they
remove it and but yeah it's not very
nice and it doesn't feel very nice so
you don't necessarily want to do that
now you can get nail varnish which lasts
you a month and it's more expensive and
yada yada but like the technological
breakthroughs Peter the is always
talking about like um technological
stagnation right like we haven't
improved on the Jet Engine and whatever
we have improved so much on beauty Tech
in that period it's amazing and I think
it's just because there's there's a
bottomless market for it people don't
actually care about flying across the
Atlantic slightly more quickly you know
that's why nail barnish that lasts for
another two weeks yeah yeah and fillers
that look more natural and never to get
wrinkles and yada yada y like
right so it's a race it's not only a
race to the bottom which women have an
endless desire for
how much uh enhancement they will go
for the minimum bar like the Overton
window uh the minimum base rate of that
has also been raised up and it's because
of intersexual competition it's because
now if you only did the beauty routine
of 40 years ago you would look
relatively bad M compared to the other
women in your peer group this is
precisely the same but not
disincentivized instead it's just an
unspoken about cartel across the board
as why women [__] in more than men it's
a price enforcement mechanism yeah but
instead of it being price enforcement
it's just competition yeah but that is
related to the female rivalry theory of
body positivity right that if you can
somehow manage to get competitors to eat
their way out of your horizontal
competition League um there's this bill
bit he's Live at Red
Rocks some the theater and he says uh if
you ladies could only support the WNBA
like you support a fat chick that keeps
on gaining weight and is no longer a
threat to you they'd be doing more
numbers than the NBA it is amazing
whenever you go on and women post
selfies for other women yeah because you
look at the comments underneath any
woman who's posted a selfie ever and it
will always be like baby look amazing
baby look amazing and and the
expectation I think is that then when
when when those women post selfies they
get the same thing back um and it's all
very kind of you know like I it's funny
like this is the nature of sort of human
instinct right you'll you'll do things
with having no idea why you're doing
them and then sometimes you'll look back
and be like oh okay like you you read
David bus or something I'm sure you've
had this experience and you're like oh
yeah I've done that there I am and
you'll keep doing it anyway well think
about why women buy luxury goods like
why is it that women are so concerned
about having a a YSL purse it's for the
girls and the gays not for men a mulbury
handbag so there was a really
interesting study that I looked at that
uh
showed the the gift that highly inter
sexually competitive women with wealthy
spouses wanted the most was a gift card
to an expensive department store so they
could choose it themselves precisely
correct because want to use the signal
of my mate is so invested oh you want to
go after my mate yes yes he spent five
grand on this tiny piece of leather that
I carry my phone in he spent 10 grand on
this wedding ring or whatever yeah right
it's an inter seexual inter sexually
competitive threat display of mate
investment yeah even when the mate's not
around y y and because men are
completely insensitive to they don't
care brands the difference between a
[__] mulbury handbag and something
from like primar I don't think men
notice things like manicures either I
think a lot of the beauty stuff like
some of it yes is orientated towards
looking younger you know that's like
that's always going to be sexually
attractive but I think a lot of the
looking really well- groomed is about
signaling to to girls and gays because
they're the ones who are actually
receiving the signals did you see my uh
post that study that was floating around
last week to do with uh that
hairdressing
uh experiment that had been done this is
phenomenal so this is where I uh
originally Justified using science my
rivalry theory of be female uh body
positivity support a recent study
published in personality and individual
differences found that women who are
high in inter seexual competitiveness
are more likely to advise women who they
perceive as potential mating threats to
cut off more hair in an attempt to
sabotage their attractiveness the
researchers studied 450 women who are
presented with hypothetical Salon
clients participants were asked to
recommend the amount of hair to be cut
cut off for each woman women who
reported high levels of intrasexual
competitiveness were more likely to
recommend that clients have more hair
cut off when the hair was in good
condition and the clients expressed a
preference for minimal cutting another
Finding is that women advise clients of
similar attractiveness as themselves to
cut off the most hair participants
effectively targeted women they
perceived as being on the same
attractiveness level potentially to try
and reduce their attractiveness longer
hair is a cue to to Youth and health
yeah men love long hair like I don't
think women realize how much men love
long hair like if you if if you read the
men are actually incredibly easy to
please right in terms of like physical
cues but the problem is that there are
two parallel stat status games going on
when it comes to female Beauty and
appearance one is attracting men which
is basically just looking youthful like
fine and fertile and then the other is
is is the much more difficult game which
is the intersexual competition game
which is about making yourself look high
status in other ways and that's where
the brands come in that's where you know
like keeping up with fashion comes in
men don't care about that but but you
have those two things going on Parallel
and occasionally they'll come into
tension occasionally there'll be some
Trend there are no Solutions only Trader
which makes you fashionable but the men
don't
like yeah that's interesting yeah like
short hair would be an example of that
although it's quite a rare for that to
be really popular but as you know
like baggy clothes or something I was
going to say like
exactly men AR going to be interested in
that but that might that might like
occasionally come around guys would be
happy with girls just permanently
wearing leggings like hot leggings like
gym shark leggings or something like
just just just go out in those with
heels yeah like it's very basic but then
again but then I mean also part of
what's driving fashion is the fact that
gay men are so overwhelmingly
overrepresented in fashion and they
don't care have absolutely no interest
no so that's why you have like really
skinny women on catwalks and stuff like
it's partly cuz the clothes kind of hang
it's easier if if everyone's a small
sample size to deal with the clothes
like fitting everyone um but I think
it's also because the more androgynous
look is just considered to be more
beautiful by gay man you see that uh
Victoria Secrets have made the radical
decision to go back to using hot models
they tried 300 pound mannequins they
tried a trans person they tried a man
they tried the captain of the US soccer
team and radically now they're just
going to use hot chicks you know you
know that Jim brandley Lemon MH like
expensive gym where I can't tell you how
much lemon I own it's disgusting anyway
um they used to have a rule that they
didn't even stock sizes over like a UK
size 12 or UK 14 like the average woman
is a 16 that's a smarter version of what
abian Fitch did where they wouldn't give
away their clothes to homeless people
they'd just burn
them yeah you don't even give them away
to un like acceptable customers let
alone yeah no I really think that lul L
and actually the guy who found would say
quite so forly like I don't want fat
chicks wearing my clothes basically like
they they knew that having it being
associated with skinny women was
aspirational but then they changed that
in like 2020 is cu could survive
couldn't survive and now they have now
they have loads of plus-sized models and
stuff um it's a fashion though it won't
last Louise Perry ladies and gentlemen
Louise I love you I I really really
enjoy bringing you on your podcast's
great your writing's great where should
people go if they want to watch the
stuff that you uh so my podcast is
called made mother matriarch it's on
YouTube substack all the places you get
your podcasts my first book was the case
against the sexual Revolution which came
out last year I'm working on another one
as well which is going to be out um uh
in about 18 months which is
on motherhood fertility birth rates all
of this stuff um and uh I I just write I
I work too much I write for too many
places like countless places I'm on
Twitter everyone should go and read the
case against the sexual Revolution it's
phenomenal and I'm excited to see what
you do with your next one thank you for
today thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode you will
love my fulllength 2hour Long podcast
with Douglas Murray go
on press it